so a while back we built a table out of
snow
and let it freeze overnight today it's
time to find out who's the king
of the ice table official king of the
table draw
okay
roller chop
[Music]
here
no a bit of side spin in the shot
good sir
oh no i i couldn't see anything my hat
was in by my eyes you was deployed i
want to see the video reverb
yeah okay it was on
interesting change of conditions here i
know it's really started to snow yeah
[Music]
good rally
[Music]
oh
i had to go for the hard work
why is looping so hard you should just
play it safe
[Music]
[Music]
i'm so ready for the forehand
[Music]
aye
hello
yeah okay i need to start my comeback
that's a proper way to start your
contact you still
haven't there to do all these years that
don't give me
there that's the biggest mistake you can
make but you still do it
yeah of course
no i can't
[Music]
huh
this is where the best reflex training
there is yeah
but the reaction was really good huge
compact so far
[Music]
what
that was crazy forehand
no that was literally impossible
[Music]
that was nice
sneaky
oh come on
oh that was good
no match points
yes for the big one
but playing it very safe
[Music]
good save
your knee down tactic didn't work oh
it's another match pointed
[Music]
good match good match thanks for
watching until next time